- This video was made
possible by Tab for a Cause.
Raise money for charity just by opening
tabs in your browser.
With the Mueller Report out,
we finally have some answers
about Russian efforts
to interfere with the 2016 election
and the administration's efforts
to stymie that investigation.
But some of our original
questions remain unanswered.
The report raises new questions
and now we have to start
thinking about next steps.
(horn music)
Hey, Legal Eagles, today we're talking
about the known unknowns that remain
in the wake of the
redacted Mueller Report.
As we discussed in a prior video,
Robert Mueller created a legal framework
that would not have allowed him
to indict a sitting president
or to levy formal charges
against the president
on fairness grounds.
The issue from a legal perspective
is we don't know if Mr. Mueller is correct
about the unindictability
of the president.
This is largely a constitutional question.
We have memos from the
Office of Legal Counsel,
the OLC, that talk about this,
but the OLC memos themselves
are not consistent on this point.
And the OLC itself is an
arm of the executive branch
so it would not be surprising
if they took the view that their boss
cannot be indicted while
sitting in the executive office.
The only way to know
if a sitting president
can in fact be indicted
or to have formal charges
levied against them is
to test it at the Supreme Court.
And Mueller's framework that he created
certainly doesn't allow
for this possibility
which leads us to the second open question
which is what about the
statue of limitations
during the pendency of
a president's tenure?
Mueller takes the view that he cannot
indict a sitting president.
We don't know if he
actually would have indicted
the president, but he takes the position
that he is not even going
to get to that question.
But because we don't know
if Mueller is correct,
we also don't know what happens
to potential crimes that
a president committed
before taking office.
Generally speaking, most crimes
have a statute of limitations.
It's in society's interest for most things
to be able to lay to rest
certain offenses that happened so long ago
that it would be impractical to try
and get a conviction years
or decades after the fact.
So, there's a sun-setting provision
after certain offenses have happened.
It's not true for all crimes,
but it certainly applies to most of things
that you can imagine a
president having done
before or during office.
With respect to obstruction of justice,
section 3282 of title 18 of the US Code
is the general statute of limitations
that applies when there
isn't a more specific
statute of limitations.
It states that "Except as otherwise
"expressly provided by law,
"a prosecution for non-capital offense
"shall be instituted within five years
"after the offense was committed."
So, unless there is a more
specific statute of limitations
in the federal system, it's
generally a five-year statute.
So, practically speaking, even
if a sitting president committed the crime
of obstruction of justice,
what happens if the president is president
for more than five years?
What if the president wins a second term?
And has committed this particular crime.
Theoretically, if a president committed
the crime of obstruction of justice
and then won his second term,
then becoming president could be like
a get out of jail free card
which I don't think anyone would support.
And that also raises the questions
about offenses that
might have been committed
before taking office.
Those offenses may not have
a five-year statute of limitations.
There could be a two or
four statute of limitations
for fraud-related offenses.
Or there could be a very specific
one-year statute of limitations,
as sometimes happens in statutory law.
This is an untested part of the law.
Robert Mueller's position
is perfectly reasonable
that you cannot indict
a sitting president,
at least criminally speaking.
And the corollary to that argument
would probably be that well,
you can't actually indict
the sitting president
with the crime, that means
that the statute of limitations
should be told for that period of time,
but it's entirely possible
that if the question
ever got to the Supreme Court,
the Supreme Court says,
no, no, no, Mr. Mueller was incorrect,
you can indict a sitting president
and as a result, the
statute of limitations
is not told and also, by the way,
you waited too long to bring the crime
and therefore, the statute of limitations
has expired and the
president can no longer
be charged with this offense,
even after leaving the presidency.
That's the problem with
having these untested
constitutional questions that only
the Supreme Court can
answer in this context.
Which brings us to the next open question.
We don't know to what degree of certainty
Mr. Mueller thinks that the president
may or may not have committed the crime
of obstruction of justice
and knowing to what degree of certainty
the evidence rises would probably
help the electorate
and members of congress
to know what they should be doing
in terms of next steps.
While the Mueller Report itself
is often silent about how strong
Mueller thinks the evidence is,
Attorney General Barr
in his press conference
shortly before the redacted Mueller Report
was released, said that Mueller told him
in person that he wouldn't have found
a crime even in the absence
of the legal limitations that were created
as a result of the framework
under which Mueller operated.
- On March 5th, we specifically asked him
about the OLC opinion and whether or not
he was taking the position
that he would have found a crime
but for the existence of the OLC opinion
and he made it very clear,
several times that that
was not his position.
Frankly, given the descriptions
of the factual evidence
regarding obstruction,
it's hard to believe that
Mueller actually said
he would not have made
an actual determination.
In fact, the Mueller Report itself
says that it goes to great pains
to avoid the traditional
prosecutorial decisions,
and in fact, the Mueller Report says
that while he did find
evidence of conspiracy
to collude with Russians,
that evidence did not rise to the level
of a chargeable offense.
So if Mueller was capable and willing
to find that the evidence did not rise
to the level of a chargeable conspiracy
with respect to Volume
1 of the Mueller Report,
it doesn't make any sense
that he would have in secret
felt the same way about Volume 2,
the obstruction offenses,
but left it out of the
Mueller Report itself
and only told the Attorney
General William Barr.
That frankly does not sound accurate.
Which leads me to the next open question
about Attorney General Barr.
In Barr's four-page summary
of the Mueller Report,
Attorney General Barr states
that he along with Deputy
Attorney General Rod Rosenstein
looked at the evidence that Robert Mueller
created regarding obstruction
of justice and came
to a determination that
there was no obstruction.
We don't know how Barr and Rosenstein
came to this determination.
And we also don't know if it was based
on Barr's view of the evidence and facts,
or whether it was specifically
based on Barr's view of the
president's Article 2 power.
As we covered in a prior video,
Barr has a fairly idiosyncratic view
that if the president is exercising
his Article 2 power,
it cannot possibly give rise to the crime
of obstruction of justice.
The exercise of that power is effectively
unchecked by the judiciary.
There are some scholars that agree
with that view of power,
but most people disagree.
So it's important to know
how Barr and Rosenstein
came to the conclusion
that there was no obstruction of justice.
We also don't know what is behind
the redactions of the
redacted Mueller Report.
By one count, there were
855 separate redactions
on the basis of things like
harm to ongoing matters
and grand jury testimony that
is protected by Rule 6(e).
On the other hand, this is not
the most redacted
document I have ever seen
in my legal career.
I've seen documents that are
far more blacked out than this.
And it's hard to argue
that redacting information
on the basis that it's going to harm
an ongoing criminal investigation
is a bad thing to do.
But on the other hand, given the disparity
between the Barr four-page summary
and the actual redacted Mueller Report,
I'm not sure that this Justice Department
deserves the benefit of the doubt
with respect to the
redactions that were made.
So, it is an open question
as to what is underneath
all of these redactions
and what we will see in the
weeks and months going forward
as it is tested in the courts
whether this information can be unredacted
and released to the public or to Congress.
Additionally, in one of the appendices
to the redacted Mueller Report,
there are 12 referrals that started
with the Mueller investigation
that were made to other
US Attorneys offices
throughout the country.
Many of those referrals
are completely unknown.
It is blacked out what the referral was,
what the subject matter was,
and we have no idea what is going to come
of these investigations that started
with the Mueller Report,
but were farmed out to the
other US Attorneys offices
throughout the country that
have subject matter jurisdiction
over the rest of these
criminal investigations.
Now in terms of some of
the questionable decisions
that the Mueller team made,
at least from a legal perspective,
we've already talked about the legal
framework that Mueller created
that may or may not be
constitutionally mandated,
but one of the things
that really sticks out
as an attorney, is Mueller's decision
not to interview the president.
Mueller stated that he viewed his role
in this investigation as a fact-finder.
Not to come to a conclusion about
whether a sitting president
has committed a crime or not,
but to be able to gather
the relevant evidence
while it was still fresh,
while the witnesses were still available,
to be able to compile that
so that other people and other entities
would be able to make
those determinations.
So given that, it is odd
that the Mueller team
decided not to interview the president.
Again, that might have
been the right decision,
but it is an odd one in the context
of a fact-gathering mission.
So, instead of interviewing or deposing
the president, the Mueller team
decided to issue written questions
that the president was able
to respond to in writing,
having had his attorneys
look over all of his answers.
I tweeted out after the Mueller Report
was issued that depositions
are better than interrogatories.
And what I mean by that
is in the civil world,
at least, you have mechanisms in discovery
to be able to interview witnesses,
or to ask them written questions.
Written questions are
called interrogatories
and these interrogatories can be useful,
but the problem is that the opposing side
will review it dozens of times
through their attorneys
so that the information
that you receive is not
particularly useful.
Getting someone in front of a camera,
in front of a stenographer under oath,
and asking them oral questions
is almost always a far better way
to understand what they were thinking,
why they did certain actions
and to actually get at the truth.
Credit where credit is due,
I would say it was a very smart tactic
of President Trump's attorneys
to prevent and delay him from sitting
in front of an oral deposition
and in issuing these written answers
that are very, very safe,
and basically don't say anything
that could incriminate the president.
It was good legal advice.
We, of course, knew that the president
was given written questions,
but until now, we were
not able to see them.
Now, we can finally see the questions
and answers that are listed in Appendix C
to the redacted Mueller Report.
Almost all of the president's answers
come in the form of I don't know
or I don't recall, which is of course,
a very, very safe thing to do.
It is hard to get locked down
in terms of lying under oath
or committing perjury
when you're simply saying
that you don't have a
specific recollection
of the thing that is asked of you.
The amount of I don't
knows and I don't recalls
is interesting also, for the fact,
that the president has claimed to have
one of the greatest memories
in the entire world.
- One of the great memories of all time.
- But that's the issue with
getting written answers.
They aren't written by the answerer,
they are written by the lawyers
and simply signed onto by the person
who is asked the questions.
But Mr. Mueller says that he found
Trump's written answers
to be, quote, inadequate.
And says that the special counsel
had the power to subpoena the president
to make him sit for deposition.
But Mueller refrained from doing so
because issuing a subpoena
would oppose, quote,
substantial delay, and he felt
like he already had enough information.
Those are not unreasonable concerns,
but given the circumstances,
this would have been a
very difficult decision
and only time will tell
whether it was the right one.
So in the wake of the Mueller Report,
let's talk about next steps.
Mueller recognizes that
impeachment is the preferred
and constitutionally-sanctioned
mechanism here.
He specifically states that Congress
can in fact police
wrong-doing by the executive,
whether the allegations
of the Mueller Report
rise to the level of impeachment
is a political question
that I will leave to you.
But Mueller and his team concluded
that Congress does, in fact,
have the authority to police
obstruction of justice,
stating, "We concluded that Congress
"has the authority to
prohibit a president's
"corrupt use of his authority
"in order to protect the integrity
"of the administration of justice."
I think it's clear that the reason
that this is in the Mueller Report
is that this is a rebuke
of Attorney General Barr's
view that you can't use the president's
inherent authority as a predicate
for obstruction of justice.
Mueller and his team did
not buy that argument.
Moreover, Mueller recognizes
that actual criminal prosecution
is an option after the
president leaves office,
as does the OLC memo
on which the DOJ policy
not to indict a sitting
president is based.
Specifically, that quote,
"The president does not have
"immunity after he leaves office."
This is a further rebuke of Barr's view
about the constitutional unitary
executive defense that would otherwise
have prevented a sitting president
from facing charges related to actions
that he or she took while in office.
House Judiciary Chair Jerry Nadler
has issued a subpoena for
the full Mueller Report
and the underlying evidence related
to the investigation.
It remains to be seen
what could be contained
in those redacted portions.
And of course, we've talked
about the referrals that are out.
There are dozens of cases
that were referred out
and we don't even know
the first thing about
the nature of those cases.
There are also rumblings
that a few Democratic
members of the House are pushing
for impeachment hearings.
Whether this is a good political move
or whether impeachment even
has a chance of passing
is beyond the scope of this channel
and that's a political question
that I will leave to you.
But here's what we can know for sure
about the next steps.
Number one, the courts will decide
whether to release the
unredacted Mueller Report
and the underlying evidence.
Number two, the dozen or so referrals
to the other US Attorneys offices
will likely in further indictments
of whom, it's anyone's guess.
But recall that one of those referrals
led to the president's personal attorney's
office being searched
and that's a huge deal.
It's likely that at least some
other people will be indicted.
And number three, elected representatives
will have to decide whether
to move forward with impeachment.
Impeachment is a political tool.
And it will be up to the
politicians to decide
whether to use that measure or not.
One other potential next step
is perhaps do some good for this world.
If this video leaves you wanting to make
some positive change in the world,
I'd recommend Tab for a Cause
which lets you raise money for the charity
of your choice just by opening tabs
which you were going to do anyway.
Tab for a Cause is a
Google Chrome extension
that allows you to pick
the charity of your choice
and then every time you open up a new tab,
instead of it being blank,
it displays a couple of ads and the money
that you generate is
donated to your charity.
There is no charge to you
and it actually does
some good for this world.
Tab for a Cause users have raised
hundreds of thousands
of dollars for charity.
It's the easiest possible way
to do some good in this world.
So all you have to do is just click
the link in the description and sign up
with Tab for a Cause.
And do some good by doing what you
were going to do anyway
by browsing the internet.
Do you have other open questions?
Do you agree with my analysis?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out my other
Real Law Reviews over here
where I will see you in court.